i'm excited to announce the third annual
blockchain 50 list of billion dollar
companies
taking blockchain and cryptocurrencies
seriously notably this year we had a big
difference over the previous two years
and that we saw
institutions and enterprises actually
using
cryptocurrency itself in past years we
had seen mostly that these
big well-known companies were really
looking at the
underlying technology which is called
blockchain
um and looking at other ways that they
could use it to bring efficiency to
their internal systems
but they were a little reluctant to get
into bitcoin ethereum and other
cryptocurrencies
this year we saw that starting to change
another big trend that we saw this year
was
a decrease in the percentage of
companies from the united states
and an increase in companies from asia
generally speaking but
specifically china i think if you look
at those two
trends together you will largely see
uh the the biggest identity shift in
this year's blockchain 50.
on the cryptocurrency side of things
there's two that really jump out the
first is paypal
obviously this is one of the biggest
payment companies in the world
last year in 2020 paypal took the giant
step of letting its 30 million merchants
receive bitcoin as payment for everyday
goods
before that moment people largely
thought of cryptocurrency as
an investable asset something more like
gold than a dollar
and they were buying it and they were
holding it now i i think that it to a
large degree that's
still happening but paypal's building
technology that is
specifically meant to make it easier and
even to encourage
people to spend bitcoin now if this
happens it would be a monumental shift
for the cryptocurrency space
the second company that i think best
highlights
the rise of institutional use of
cryptocurrency
is square in a lot of ways square is a
competitor to paypal famously led by
jack dorsey who last year came out
swinging as a big supporter of bitcoin
not only as a way to spend money but as
an investable asset
he has done everything from create
software
nonprofit organization that is giving
away intellectual property related to
cryptocurrency to making it easier for
his customers
to invest in cryptocurrency we removed
facebook google amazon
and one of the most widely used
cryptocurrency companies ripple from our
blockchain 50 list
while all of these companies continue to
use and explore blockchain
we just thought that when we looked at
some of the other companies and the
seriousness with which they were
exploring the technology
they just weren't they weren't
competitive anymore
they were replaced by a rise of
companies
in asia there's one in particular that i
think we just have to highlight
it's it's the biggest bank in the world
um they have almost three trillion
dollars in assets under management
the industrial and commercial bank of
china which is so big it's hard to even
really think of it as a bank itself
they have dozens of blockchain
applications and they've gone
far beyond blockchain experiments these
are live applications
that are doing everything from letting
small businesses get
loans in real time to simplifying the
way that
imports and exports move across borders
in years past there was a lot of concern
about privacy issues
and regulatory concerns for these big
institutions
using public blockchains but technology
is evolving
and the ability to protect people's
privacy while still using public
blockchains
is increasingly becoming a reality and
what i think is going to happen in
future years
is we will see a movement from these
permissioned blockchains that are really
cool but maybe a little less efficient
than public blockchains
to public blockchains where they have
the best of both worlds their consumers
privacy can be protected
but they get the added efficiency of
using a ledger that is
truly public and truly open and truly
anybody can build on
[Music]